hey everyone this is steve weintraub
with collider i am thrilled to be with
the cast of mayans here at comic-con uh
gentlemen and lady how are you guys
doing good great thank you thank you for
having us i have a ton of questions for
you guys and uh but i guess i want to
start with i love learning about like
the behind the scenes the making of a
series so for fans of mayans what do you
think they would be surprised to learn
about the actual making of the show i
think just how much time goes in um with
the crew and especially the stunts
um
you know if i'd pick an episode that
first episode in in season four
um we spent uh about a week and a half
on next shoots
and uh our stunt coordinators uh just
really phenomenal you know planned
everything out everything
was so specific so that we could create
the kind of tension that we needed
for that episode because when you're
filming you don't have a lot of time
right uh so you got to have that prep so
that
come in the day everyone's going we're
all firing all cylinders i'll say
something real quick sure you know i
think uh fans and the audience they
forget they don't not they forget they
they're not really cognizant of the
craft behind of what we do sometimes you
know i think especially specifically
with our cast is like you know
it it looks and feels so real
you know because it is but they forget
that like we're acting right we're not
actually these individuals and i feel
like you know
when i'm in public or judaism i think
they forget that like we're not these
characters that aren't that are on tv
right we're actually normal human beings
that aren't bikers and gang members and
and
and
club goers and stuff like that so i
think that's the biggest thing that like
for me in my opinion the audience
forgets like this is not real life
you know it's a craft it's a craft
oh god i would say uh
you know what i i binged the show also
recently i just like did like from the
start once again just like all the way
through ten episodes and it's you know
it can be harrowing it can be dark um
and i just want everyone to know how
much joy we actually get making this
show like you know it's it's not a it's
not a comedy although there's wonderful
comedic moments but
as a whole like i just feel like it's a
joy to be on our set it's like a very
happy place
surprisingly for like how how um how
mystical sort of the the episodes are
darker shows yeah i agree i'm gonna
piggyback on that yeah i find that i you
know whenever i have to answer a
question after you like you're the
steeler of thunder like you are the
thunder stealer uh but i think i agree
with you i think it's
what i think people might be the most
surprised by is how funny everyone is on
set i mean we take it incredibly
seriously and like jd said there's not a
lot of time
but
there's an awful lot of laughter between
takes and after takes
uh
maybe we need like a b-roll
steve so that you can just see how funny
we really are we're very funny so one of
the things about this show is characters
die and i'm so curious that's hilarious
right that's
what i mean why not see wow what i'm
curious about is because you really
don't know as you're watching if a
character might be
exiting especially after this last
season what is it like for you guys
reading scripts are you ever looking at
a script and saying i think you'll
survive but everyone else is fair game
in terms of you never know so what is it
like reading scripts are you sort of
like
looking at them carefully or do you
think you'd be told by like you know
people involved that hey you're not
going to make it you know i think uh i
mean look most of the time
you you we do find out
you know we know what's what's going on
um
and
you know it's just the nature of the
beast right it's a it's um
elgin james we really pride ourselves on
on telling the truth albeit a very
cinematic and it's entertainment and
we're dramatic about it you know we had
that that dramatic license
um but in this kind of world in the the
criminal underworld there are the stakes
are high
you know there are consequences for it
and i we all know that we knew that
going in
um and you said that you know i you're
sure that i'm gonna survive well i
always had the mindset too going in that
i could possibly go you know you just
never know because at the end of the day
it's about mayans and what serves what
serves the show and i think that
we're all servants in that way you know
we all we all
give
to the show
so one of the things about the last
season is the trajectory of easy
how early on do you think he was aiming
to be president was it something that he
was looking at because it's been very
interesting watching his transition from
entering the club to this last season i
mean he got brutal and i'm just curious
when do you think it all flipped for him
in terms of the where he wanted to go
well you know elgin and i really we we
spent a lot of time talking about this
even even like from the beginning about
how
easy
was the kind of guy who wherever he goes
he can't help but take the leadership
role not necessarily because he wanted
it or or aims for it but because that's
just who he is so the past seasons he's
he's always been one foot in one foot
out you know because he's had this
resentment this regret of thinking that
his life was supposed to be something
different and until recent events and
then seeing what was happening to the
club
he finally stepped into his place
and that's probably a very hard thing to
watch a hard thing to understand because
sometimes when you do take that
leadership role it's not about making
friends it's about doing what's best for
the group and you're going to have
people who understand that and people
who don't understand that and right now
the mayans are at war and so it's about
survival
so to answer your question
it was probably this season
where in talking with alvarez and
constantly saying we're at war we're at
war what are we going to do and then
seeing a man who was more about his
family an easy understanding oh
that's great but that does not work for
us so i have to step forward one of the
things that has been interesting is the
they've been talking about the fact that
you're all related for a long time and
the finale or who's that
what who are you speaking of the the
show i mean who's all related oh the
three of you guys oh interesting right
now i'm not familiar yet yeah
with information that i haven't heard of
thank you very much
what are you talking about sir so what
i'm curious about though is how um
uh talk a little bit about what that
means going forward for the show because
it's been something that's been toyed
with and talked about but not really you
know the the realization has been you
know the the curtain's been pulled i
mean how do you react when
your greatest adversary
adversaries
could be your only blood relatives
i mean that i think that's what
elgin does so well i mean it's
shakespearean it's greek and you know in
its scope and
you know to be able to still be
uh grounded and human
and you know to be able to really
breathe into those stakes that i think
given anybody else would would be
melodramatic but elgin uh raises it to
that poetic level while still grounding
it to you know the stakes of
these these people who need uh support
so badly because they're in such dire
straits whether it's you know violence
or you know backstabbing or whatever it
might be
seeking power uh that the people who
they need the most could actually be
their their biggest enemies making a
show like this you obviously have action
you have character moments long dialogue
scenes for each of you what's actually
the stuff you really love doing on set
and the stuff that you're like oh when
you see it in the script you're like
that's going to be a f and d can i
answer this please uh so my favorite
things as far as like filming is uh
anytime i have a scene with jd
i think
you know obviously our characters were
brothers but i just think with you know
with jd as a person and me as well it's
like it's there's just a symbiotic
[ __ ]
just temple that we have with each other
right now and it's um
as far as acting i can't i've never been
able to replicate it or duplicate it
because it's this is rare the the type
of chemistry that our characters both
have
um so that's something that i really i'm
very uh appreciative of and it's not
something that again like i said it's
not something that you always come
across when you're acting um
for me the the worst part is when we
have these long days when we're doing
physical stuff and we're running
um
especially in the boots that we wear
i have the worst shin splints dude i get
the worst since once and i'm taking five
advils and i'm still in pain crying but
i can't show any of that so that's my
worst dude soft i'm so soft i'm so soft
yeah it's like yeah i'm like yeah i'm
like ice cream i didn't want to say
anything but i heard rumors yeah oh well
you're right if you heard rumors of
being ice cream that's me right um
uh you know this year
emily's been very removed from all the
things we've known about the show thus
far be it like santo father santa monday
like the the uh
the town the galindo house like all
these things that we've we've we know
and love and now she's been paired back
she's been removed and there's it's
two-pronged it is both
it's so enjoyable for me to create that
isolation for emily and that um that
reduced life that she you know that
castle on the hill to this to this level
of um impoverished freedom
uh and simultaneously i don't get to
work with these lovely actors i am
mostly for this season i am alone with
our glorious crew and thank goodness for
them but i i don't get to i'm miss doing
scenes with y'all it's always next
season yeah
i think i think the season maybe sets up
the finale maybe sets up a a different
version of the show steve do you know
something we don't know you're talking
about are you just dropping knowledge on
this right here listen i i'm what we
call a tv fan and i have watched a lot
of television and i think that the
separation of the season leads to a
you know it's pretty uh it's pretty you
know i think the four of you are going
to be doing scenes together in the
not-so-distant
future you haven't started
congratulations
thank you appreciate you i have to rap
though but when do you start filming
again are you
thank you steve for your time this has
been a great time here at comic con
uh thank your fans that was a really
i'm a big fan i knew you were going to
do it and i said to to show my fandom i
will also do my nails
there you go that's actually not true at
all
i appreciate them
i also appreciate you guys each giving
me five bucks to make them feel good
that was fantastic
right i mean listen uh for all the
people that uh have not actually watched
mayans i give it a really strong
endorsement it's oh i almost cursed it's
a very good show and i i agree i love
the like shakespearean uh like you know
it it's up and down it's left and right
and uh anyway thank you so much for
coming in so much really appreciate it
thank you to the fans too thank you